I feel like that's how gangbangs work
sometimes I'm like you you and I guess
everyone else
see somebody go like this
[Music]
here's some good space news in a way
space I love space like like Galaxy [__]
yeah the kind you like so uh 40 light
years away they discovered a planet
that's made completely of burning hot
lava that doesn't sound real that sounds
like a sun
sounds like a son yeah it's actually a
planet that's rotating so close to its
star that it's constantly on fire yeah
they call it the hell Planet imagine
getting banished to Hell Planet I know
it's just hot all day you're like ah so
[__] hot man there's nothing but lava
to eat I hate this place there's
actually an advantage to it like
scientists are super stoked about
finding it they're so stoked because
it's hot and you could like launch
people today
the new Australian all your criminals
shoot Andrew Tate there all the dates
yeah so it turns out because it's
actually aside from the burning hot fire
part it's actually pretty similar to
like what a super Earth would be so what
they think is except from the burning
except just the hot fire part just that
one detail yeah so they think that they
can study it and find out if other
habitable planets that look like Earth
have a chance of just becoming that like
if we could become like a hot planet
yeah like like what if they fight you
know like right now they're trying to
find Like A New Earth like to move
because we [__] this one let's avoid
that one now yeah it's like I'm not
interested in it yeah I don't like it
but they think that there's a chance
that that used to be a normal planet and
it turn hot yes it turned into hail that
way they can tell if they find a new
planet that's like Earth if they go it
might look like a nice Planet but it it
could be like what if that was a
precursor because you know Hawaii was
like volcano right and then lava and
lava becomes Island also like if that's
a gonna be when it cools down it's gonna
be Earth yeah when it cools down or if
it causes massive rain or some [__] and
then that you need those to become Earth
but that that's the reason why that
one's burning is because it's too close
to its Star right so that means it's
probably not gonna but what if the sun
cools down yeah the sun gets old is it
gonna end up getting a little far from
its star like yeah maybe actually when
Suns get old they expand I don't know I
guess that place is kind of toasted yeah
it is yeah not the vibe would you guys
live on Mars if you could nope [__] that
I wouldn't want to be the first I
wouldn't want to be apparently there's
like some live streaming going on Mars
like the the other like yesterday
it looked like like Nevada bro yeah it
does it looked regular yeah Mars just
looks like Las Vegas yeah without the
casinos yeah and the strip club
I'm super down to visit you want to
visit hell Planet visit Mars even if
it's gonna take like a year there Year
back you'd be like um that's cool maybe
I think 50 years from now that's what
rich people will do it's like right now
you can visit the homie in like Tahiti
it's like nah bro chill up chill with me
and Mark yeah yeah I got this little
desert they cracked that light speed it
only takes three minutes to get there I
kind of want to go to Tahiti before Mars
yeah but because you know what Tahiti
looks like and you're like I can't wait
to go there and when we know what Mars
looks like and I don't feel like I can't
wait to go there because I could go to
Mojave Desert yeah I could go to Las
Vegas I feel like they're different but
sure yeah yeah but also but it looks the
same the only people that are going to
be able to like get to Mars are gonna be
the rich like pieces of [__] and then
they're gonna land on March and try to
like create a whole civilization this
whole thing they're gonna like rule we
might make the diversity play it'll be
like Dubai yeah yeah for sure oh okay I
guess yeah I guess you're right okay I
have a better scenario
Spirit Airlines now offers Mars as a
destination I'll go to tpd Spirit
I guarantee you if Spirit Airlines goes
to Mars it's a 19 ticket so you get to
go to Mars for 19 the charger for the
oxygen and the [__] what costs they
don't even have a charger in their car
like you know your phone died your phone
dies
it's a year-long flight yeah [__] that
cause I fly Spirit but my rule is only
an hour away have you guys seen that
like
if they had a soul plane to Mars I might
be down I might be down the journey is
pretty important for a year you'd be on
Soul Plane for a year
it's for the run time
if you had to be in a soul train
for a year to Mars who would be your
five homies I would have Barack Obama
because he's hot I would just because
he's the first man is Barack Obama you
said homies you're like Barack Obama at
first you're immediately just thinking
about a guy to [__] yeah you're the hot
guy he's a cool guy you probably have a
lot to say too yeah yeah I like the way
he talks
um I probably would have um Shakira
I would pick
I would pick I don't know I would pick
this guy this guy's funny this guy's
funny fart yeah no I would pick this guy
and this guy well I'll pick all of you
guys yeah yeah no no no no no
you pick Mark first it's all good yeah
we don't we don't we don't feel bad
about it she's like I don't want to hurt
their feelings oh yeah yeah
let's see everybody I feel like that's
how gangbangs work sometimes I'm like
you you and I guess everyone else
see somebody go like this
[Music]
the babies become yeses because I'm like
it won't you'll be in there for two
minutes it won't really matter but like
I'll walk into the gangbang party it'll
be a little Squad of dudes and it's just
like
and that guy just jacks off oh you've
never you've actually got people that
guy could jack you need to jack off
you're like damn it um you know because
I can't do like 15 dudes that's crazy
but I like to like so I used to but what
if he goes yeah what if he bags like
that I used to work at these gangbang
parties different time of my life
um and I remember they would be like you
should do this from like 4 P.M to 8 p.m
and so the first time I was a rookie and
I just [__] till I was tired so like
till two hours so like after like six
they were just like yo what are you
doing I was like hanging out by the
snack bar like
and they were like go back to work and I
was like the [__] like I just [__] for
two hours straight so the next time I
came I was like let me [__] three guys
15 minutes 10 minute break then I would
oh you Pace it out now it's like that
you you and then 10 minutes and I'm like
I would just kind of space it out to
look productive what are you eating
that's it I'm eating gushers
every gangbang party has this Costco
chicken wrap sandwiches that are like
those like pinwheels oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't know what's up with them
but like you like them they're a good
price for you get a lot for foreign
I would look productive but I actually
did way less work that way than like oh
okay I just like gang bang sound like
[__] prohibition air when people are
standing outside the factory he's
begging for work like maybe me choose me
today if I'm a professional I want you
to um psychoanalyze me I don't like
watching gangbangs but I do what I do
like watching though is multiple cream
pie you know what's crazy I don't [__]
to completion in a gangbang setting like
people think when I [__] those 50 guys
at one time they just come on you yeah
they think I'm there for like hours bro
biologically what happens in my body
with a like safe protected sex [__]
one guy for one hour versus a hundred
guys in one hour is I'm equally as ran
through it's it's like one pound of
feathers versus one pound of steel it's
the same [__] I see yeah you could have
still pounding you yeah
it's the same amount it's the same
length of time unless like one guy has
an arm you know for like a [__] dick
it's the same [__] and it's like have
you ever refused because it's like
that's just too big I have never said no
to size wow wow I've always been like I
could do it but I've definitely been
like after a minute being like chill it
you're like you're thrusting hard I'm
like toodaloo you know
but like with like gang bangs for me I
like the visual and like feeling catered
so it'll
two minutes two minutes
two minutes so it's like after 10
minutes I've like [__] Five Guys but
do you like the simultaneous or one by
one I like do you like to be the
rotisserie chicken or would you like to
be like we could I like the diversity
you know but like I feel like two is
cool and then maybe like like you know I
could do that but like those guys like I
feel like never having a good time
because it's like the most half hardened
yeah
you're multitasking yeah sometimes I
like like one by one
I just equated
yeah it's like trying to cook two
the more dicks you add the less my
performance is because it's like if you
were [__] me from behind and you're
Eiffel towering me with a dick here this
guy's getting the worst [__] of all
time oh
the more you add the shittier everyone
is everyone's just staring like the
effort distribution and do you ever feel
like now it's not about you it's about
giving too much no I feel like they have
like I feel like the guys there are like
for me so they like it so sometimes I'll
be like let's just do one by one but
it's like speed run like two mining
rounds let's go and it'll be like
they'll affect me for two minutes then
the next guy will come and [__] me for
two minutes and the next guy will [__]
me for two minutes that's the one I like
but doesn't that mean that guy the other
guy has to go and jack off later he
doesn't get to finish he'll go finish on
like another person you know like it'll
be like another like Landing Pad of nut
to like go landing pad you know out so
so so I like this one it's not a gang
bang but I don't know what it's called
but it's like a they do these marathons
bukaki no no it's not but it's like they
say like like a hundred husbands or some
[__] I forgot the title but it's a joke
it's like a kumate [__] did he die
there's just guys lined up and she [__]
one after the other and then and it just
rolls through them she makes some
[__] nut like a train I can't make
that really fast and I'm just like wow
this is real maybe in Japan you can but
I don't like oh it's like a Time tall at
the same time I feel ass too that's a
time trial the [__] video you're
helping me dude like oh that's way too
that's too much but one at a time it's
like oh she's that's what you like I
like that because it's like she makes
them come so fast it must be so good
[Music]
thank you